es gibt einige sachen die im sommer
super wichtig sind damit eure
tomatenpflanzen gesund und glücklich
bleiben und welche das sind das erzähle
ich euch in diesem fall
[Musik]
der erste tipp ist vor allem für
gewächse aus tomaten interessant weil da
kein wind weht und weil da kaum insekten
reinkommen und beides ist für die
bestimmung der tomaten und damit für die
fruchtbildung super wichtig und deswegen
müssen wir nachhelfen am besten mit
einer elektrischen zahnbürste und damit
behandeln wir dann unsere tomaten damit
simulieren wir nämlich eine hummel die
auf der blüte landet und dann vibriert
und dadurch wird der pool und wichtigen
stellen transportiert in der blüte und
das passiert einfach im gewächshaus
nicht dadurch dass wir da keine hummeln
haben und kein wind will der die pflanze
vielleicht ein bisschen durchschüttelt
ihr könnt auch wenn euch das zufällig
ist mit der elektrischen zahnbürste
einfach die tomate packen und ein
bisschen schütteln vorsichtig natürlich
diese ja nicht durchbrechen aber wenn
ihr einfach alle paar tage mal durch
euer gewächshaus geht und alle pflanzen
mal so ein bisschen durchgeschüttelt
dann belohnen sie euch mit bis zu
dreimal mehr es ist einfach unglaublich
was für ein unterschied macht also nicht
vergessen und dann gibt es eine große
gefüllte tomaten krankheit diebe fällt
meistens die freiland tomaten noch bevor
sie die gewächshaus tomaten das feld das
ist die braunfäule die kann die ernte
einfach kompletter hinreißen und dir der
schon länger gärtner hat wird das
wahrscheinlich kennen deswegen halte
immer die augen offen ob ich vielleicht
solche oder solche stellen an euren
tomaten seht was gegen die braunfäule
hilft ist vor allem diese stellen also
diese blätter und früchte die davon
befallen sind sofort zu entfernen und
dann gibt es ein richtig cooles
hausmittel dass ihr euch selber
zusammenmischen könnt die zutaten blende
ich euch jetzt mal hier ein damit die
tomaten einsprühen wenn sie gefallen
sind oder auch schon mal vorbeugend
damit behandeln und dann ist das
ausreizen auch super wichtig und das
entblättern und zu allen diesen themen
habe ich auch schon eigene videos
gemacht und die videos die für das
gesund erhalten der tomaten im sommer
wichtig sind habe ich euch nochmal hier
oben verlinkt und unten in der video
beschreibung weil sie euch dann noch mal
näher formieren wollt noch mal kurz
erklärt dass ausgrenzung bedeutet dass
ihr die seitentriebe der tomate entfernt
wir stellen uns jetzt mal vor hier so
der hauptstelle der tomate und hier
wächst ein strauß mit blättern und dann
bilden sich hier zwischen dem stängel
und dem
ersten triebe und die nickels zu
entfernen damit eure pflanze schön
luftig steht und sich die braunfäule
nicht so festsetzen kann auch alle
blätter die auf dem boden hängen auf
jeden fall entfernen und zwischendrin
auch immer mal blätter entfernen damit
die pflanzen eben schön luftig stehen
und die braunfäule keine chance hat sich
in unseren pflanzen festzusetzen
[Musik]
tomaten werden vor allem von der
braunfäule befallen wenn sie auf dem
boden hängen deswegen ist es ganz
wichtig dass man den stütze gibt oder
sie hoch beendet ich mache das im
gewächshaus so dass sich die an schnüren
hoch leite und meine freiland tomaten
bekommen so einem stab in die erde
gesteckt an dem ich die immer wieder
hoch binde damit die eben nicht auf dem
boden hängen wenn man die tomaten liest
dann auch auf jeden fall darauf achten
dass sie dabei nicht nass werden
generell sollte man freiland tomaten
auch am besten überdacht anbauen
vielleicht mit einem kleinen tomaten
haus man weiß immer nicht so genau wie
der sommer wird es gibt sommer in denen
man wunderbar im freiland tomaten
anbauen kann weil es einfach kaum regnet
weil es schön warm ist und schön trocken
und dann funktioniert das wunderbar in
anderen sommern wie zb es im sommer
hatten ganz viele leute große probleme
mit freiland tomaten weil es so viel und
so lange am stück geregnet hatte ich
dass die alle der braunfäule zum opfer
gefallen sind und das ist einfach sehr
sehr schade weil tomaten sind einfach so
wichtig und ohne tomaten ist das gerne
leben nur halb so schön und deswegen
seid ihr auf der sicheren seite wenn ihr
eure tomaten ein bisschen geschützt
anbaut es gibt einige pflanzen die man
zwischen die tomatenpflanzen kann wie
zum beispiel der rallye kommen die dafür
sorgen dass es den tomaten gut geht und
die mit den tomaten eine positive
beziehung eingehen eine symbiose eine
wunderbare tolle nachbarschaft es gibt
pflanzen die sich gegenseitig schädlinge
vom hals halten und ich bleibe euch hier
mal eine liste mit den pflanzen ein
tomaten tun und die einfach tolle
tomaten nachbarn sind weil man so auf
ganz natürliche art und weise
krankheiten und schädlingen vorbeugen
kann und dann ist es natürlich auch
wichtig die tomatenpflanzen hin zu
düngen weil sie jetzt langsam richtig
hungrig werden und da es mache ich auf
drei verschiedene arten und weisen wenn
ihr wissen wollt welche daten das sind
dann schaut gerne da drüben vorbei und
da unten verlinkt ich euch meine
playlist mit den kompletten tomaten
tipps die jetzt im sommer wichtig sind
und dann geht raus und macht die welt
ein bisschen grün